Oh my God, I'm so thrilled
that you're all here.
I feel like a lot of the time
you get to speak to one person
who's involved in a project,
but not, you know, the whole family
which you're gonna have
different perspectives,
which is a lot of what your film's about.
Family and different perspectives.
And I just knew out of the
gate when I was watching it,
I was like this is someone, it seemed,
tell me if I'm correct,
very personal for you.
- That's exactly right.
Yeah, thank you for saying that.
So yeah, Finn plays a character
who is like a rockstar online.
He has 20,000 followers around the world
from Belarus to Bangladesh.
And his mom is, she runs a
domestic violence shelter,
and the two of them have
like a clash of culture,
generation, and values.
- Okay, Finn, I'm so
excited to talk to you.
I actually got to hang out
with Millie Bobby Brown.
She did the show, but I heard recently
that she was talking about
onscreen kissing with you,
and she was teasing that you were-
- Lousy?
- Yeah.
- [Alisha] Quote-unquote lousy.
- And you guys are like
brother and sister,
like you, and Noah, and
her have grown up together,
you have raised each
other in certain ways.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- How did you feel
about your family member
calling you a lousy kisser?
- Yeah, you know what?
My first like onscreen
kiss was with Millie,
and so but I didn't know how to like
approach that in any way.
There was no, just was like,
you're gonna do this thing
and at the end of the take
you're gonna kiss her.
And then so I just like, kinda just like
almost like head butted her.
And then-
- That's the romantic way of putting it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The romantic way of
putting it was that yeah,
I head butted her.
- Well, I've had to kiss a
lot of people over the years.
It's very mechanical and I was excited
'cause I was gonna kiss
my boyfriend, at the time,
on screen, Luke Wilson.
And I was like, this is gonna be great.
And then he kissed me in the scene like,
and I was like I thought
this was gonna be different.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, oh, that's so weird.
He gave me the pursed lips
- Like, I even give open mouth, you know?
Okay, well I just had to
talk to you about that
'cause I feel like-
- It's a weird thing.
- Onscreen kissing is a weird world.
Okay, Alisha used to write
screenplays based on movies.
Is this true?
- Yeah, it's not really impressive at all.
Oh my god.
- [Drew] Oh my god.
- [Jesse] Oh my god, that's so sweet.
- Straight from my Insta, wow.
So basically I was obsessed
with the "Cheetah Girls"
movie, and apparently...
(audience applauding)
Lot of fans.
They made the movie into a book
you could buy at Barnes
and Noble and read it
with pictures in it and stuff.
Then I took that book
that was already a movie
and made my own, like wrote it up myself
and made my own screenplay and
made my friends act it out.
But it was already a movie.
It was just so-
- What is unimpressive about that?
- I mean, like 'cause it
was already a film and-
- No. This is so smart.
- Thank you, Drew.
- That's amazing to me.
- That's what you were going for, right?
- That's exactly what I was going for.
- [Finn] Yeah.
- All right, so what was it like
to work with Jesse as a director?
- I loved it.
I was extremely intimidated at first
'cause I was fan of you.
- Of course, of course.
- Still am. Not was.
Of course, of course, you knew.
- I'm like the least intimidating person.
- Yeah, I know.
And then I met you and-
- If you drew a picture of
the least intimidating person
who's still a human being, I
think it would look like me.
- I'm honestly intimidated by all actors.
I feel like they're, I
mean, you just wanted,
you meet people, you meet other actors
and you want to be
challenged and you want to
just drop into the space
and feel really comfortable,
and I was just nervous.
It was like the first
time I'd worked in a year
'cause this was 2021 January,
and I'd been like cooped up in a house
and I was just nervous all around,
and then Jesse just made
me feel so comfortable
and was so open to collaborating.
- Well, you did a wonderful job
helming and leading this beautiful story
about humanity, and families,
and what's important
to do with a life and figure
that out along the way
and take care of other people.
'Cause I was like, what
does the title mean?
And when I saw the film, you get it.
We have a clip of "When You
Finish Saving The World."
Let's take a look at it please.
- You don't have to be
interested in politics.
- But I am.
- [Alisha] No, you're not.
It's obvious, but it's cool.
- You think I'm stupid?
- No, no, I didn't say that.
- {Finn] So can you teach me?
- About what?
- I watch you talk about things.
Like, baked things and you talk about them
with such passion.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, perfect.
Jesse Eisenberg, Finn
Wolfhard, and Alisha Boe.
"When You Finish Saving The World"
is in theaters tomorrow.
(upbeat bright music)